الان الى الاراضي المحتله حيث تتسارع
وتيره التصعيد بشكل ملحوظ بموازاه تشكيل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده برئاسه
بنيامين نتنياهو فقد استشهد فجر هذا اليوم
شاب فلسطيني متاثرا باصابته برصاصه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه في مدينه كفر قاسم في منطقه
المثلث الجنوبيه داخل الخط الاخضر السلطات
الاسرائيليه قالت انه حاول تنفيذ عمليه
اطلاق نار وده اسفلت عن اصابه اثنين من
افرادها بجروح طفيفه بينما اشاد رئيس
الحكومه المنتهيه ولاياته
بعمل افراد الشرطه الاسرائيليه وبتعمولهم
مع ما هو وصفه بالعمليه التخريبيه من
جهتها قالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه في بيان
انه تم العثور على قطعه سلاح داخل المركبه
التي استخدمت في الهجوم وزجاجات حارقه
وذخيره في احد المباني القريبه من مكان
وقوعي الحادث خلال عمليات التمشيط والبحث
عن مشتبه بهم اخرين من جهتها نفت عائله
الشهيد نعيم بدير ايكون ابنها قد قام
بتنفيذ هجوم ضد عناصر الشرطه الاسرائيليه
وقالت انه قتل بدا من بارد